Hark! The herald angels sing Glory to the newborn King
Peace on earth and mercy mild God and sinners reconciled
Joyful all ye nations rise Join the triumph of the skies
With angelic hosts proclaim Christ is born in Bethlehem
Hark! The angels sing Hark! The angels sing Glory to the newborn King
Christ my highest heaven adored Christ the everlasting Lord
it's for a long time that we've been able to do this um so we're going to uh get started here in a
couple of minutes we've got a great program uh ready for you guys and i'm going to start you
guys start us off with a quick prayer uh lord thank you so much for uh just this ability to
get together uh thank you so much for just this season um even though it's not exactly what we've
been thinking that this was going to be uh for this year but we are still thankful that we had
this opportunity to be able to get together uh just be reminded of you your son um and what
this season really means to us uh i pray that you just uh be with everyone that is working
and behind the scenes to make this work and i pray that um you just open up our hearts and
minds for all that we're uh for this particular part of the year for us lord in christ's name
i pray amen
the scripture reading will come from the book of isaiah chapter 7 verses 10 through 14
the sign of emmanuel later the lord sent his message to king ahaz ask the lord your god for
a sign of confirmation ahaz make it as difficult as you want as high as heaven or as deep as the
place of the dead but the king refused no he said i will not test the lord like that
then isaiah said listen well you royal family of david isn't it enough to exhaust human patience
must you exhaust the patience of
of my god as well all right then the lord himself will give you the sign
look the virgin will conceive a child she will give birth to a son
and we'll call him emmanuel which means god is with us
oh
some
is
rejoice
come to me
all peoples
and fill the world with
rejoice rejoice
rejoice
shall come to me
shall come to thee
psalm 96 1 through 13 sing to the lord a new song sing to the lord all the earth
sing to the lord praise his name proclaim his salvation day after day declare his glory among
the nations his marvelous deeds among all people for great is the lord and most worthy of praise
he is to be feared above all gods for all the gods of the nations are idols but the lord
made the heavens splendor and majesty are before him strength and glory are in his sanctuary
ascribe to the lord all you families of nations ascribe to the lord glory and strength ascribe
to the lord the glory to his name bring an offering and come into his courts worship the
lord in the splendor of his holiness tremble before him all the earth say among the nations
the lord reigns the world is firmly established it cannot be moved he will judge the peoples with
equity let the heavens rejoice let the earth be glad let the sea resound and all that is in it
let the fields be jubilant and everything in them let all the trees of the forest sing for joy
let all creation rejoice before the lord for he comes he comes to judge the earth
he will judge the earth in righteousness and the peoples in his faithfulness
so
joy to the world the lord is
in heaven and nature sing in turn nature sing in heaven
we will sing
he will sing
joy to the world
from hills and plains
repeat the sounding joy
repeat, repeat the sounding joy
he will sing
joy to the world
he will sing, sing, sing
he rules the world
with truth and grace
and makes the nations prove
the glories of his righteousness
and wonders of his love
and wonders, wonders of his love
he will sing, sing, sing
joy to the world
joyful, joyful
we adore thee
God of glory
Lord of love
hearts of all life
love before thee
holy to the Son of God
joyful, joyful
we adore thee
God of glory
Lord of love
hearts of all life
love before thee
holy to the Son of God
he will sing, sing, sing
joy to the world
Titus 2, 11-14
for the grace of God
has been revealed
bringing salvation to all people
and we are instructed
to turn from godless living
and sinful pleasures
we should live in this evil world
with wisdom, righteousness
and devotion to God
while we look forward
with hope to that wonderful day
when the glory of our great God and Savior
Jesus Christ will be revealed
to give us life, to free us
from every kind of sin
to cleanse us and to make us
his very own people
totally committed to doing good deeds
O little town of Bethlehem
how still we see thee lie
above thy deep and dreamless sleep
the stars, stars go by
yet in thy dark streets shineth
the everlasting light
the hopes and fears of all the years
are met in thee tonight
how silently, how silently
the wondrous gift was given
so God imparts to human hearts
the blessings of his heaven
no ear may hear his calling
but in this world of sin
where meek souls will receive him still
the dear Christ enters in
the hopes and fears of all the years
are met in thee tonight
Will you pray with me?
Lord Jesus, we thank you
for the way you've entered into our world
and our lives.
And this has been such a year of the unexpected
and many of us feel really tossed about
and I pray that this Christmas, God, would be a time of
again being just grounded and rooted in you
a time where we begin to sense again
that you're near us, that you're for us.
God, so this Christmas, would you draw us to yourself?
Connect us to one another
and fill our hearts with gratitude.
It's in the life-changing name of Jesus that I pray.
Amen.
Well, Merry Christmas everyone.
You made it.
You did it.
Can you give yourselves a hand?
With your little muted hands of...
You know, this is...
One thing I can guarantee is that
this will be an unforgettable Christmas Eve service.
Literally, you will never, ever forget it.
I'm imagining... I mean, I can't believe honestly that it's been
just a year ago!
Like, we were right in there.
It's weird how time right now...
Have y'all noticed this?
That time is speeding up and then slowing down
and then it's such a strange...
In ways that feel so quick,
in other ways it feels like a decade.
Oh, what a year.
But I really am so, so grateful
just to be here with all of you.
I know it's a strange way to gather,
but it's really good to be with you all
and to be together kind of as best we can.
So, welcome for all of you,
and especially those of you who are new here.
Maybe this is your first time visiting,
or maybe you've been connecting online
and this is your first time to see some faces of people.
You've probably seen Facebook profile pictures.
That's how some of you know each other.
It's like, oh yeah, I've seen your Facebook page!
But I'm really glad that you're able to connect in this way.
So, this Christmas Eve,
the title of my message,
which, don't worry,
this will not be an hour-long message.
I'm going to try to keep this as quick as I can.
This will be short.
My title is,
The Two Names.
And where I got this idea was,
so if you read the Christmas story,
which a few very special people
in just a few minutes are going to come up
and they'll read this little passage.
It's from Matthew chapter 1.
It is the Christmas story.
And it's really kind of one of two versions.
And in this story,
the child, born to Mary,
is given two names.
Now, the first name is the more popular one.
Any guesses? How about any kids?
Do you have any guesses as to the name?
The first name mentioned of this little child?
Any brave souls?
It's like the most classic name
for the little baby.
Jesus?
Is that what you said?
You're totally right.
Jesus, yes.
Good job, Lucy.
Yeah, so the first name is Jesus.
And the name Jesus means God saves.
That's the first name.
That's verse 21.
It's the angel speaking to Joseph
and says that Mary will give birth to a son
and you are to call him Jesus.
So that's the first name.
The second name, this is not as well known.
It made it into a song earlier.
Lucy has her hand up,
but I do want to give first dibs to anyone,
any kids, you know the second name.
It's verse 23.
If not, it's going to go to Lucy again.
Anyone remember the second name given to the baby?
You've got to yell it out.
Emmanuel, very good.
That was my boy.
Good job, buddy.
Emmanuel, which means God with us.
So if you put these two names together,
it gives you kind of the big idea
for my message this afternoon,
which is just this.
God saves by drawing close.
And I want to kind of unpack this.
So the first part, of course, is God saves.
So this comes from the name Jesus,
which literally translated is God saves.
However, in the passage,
the angel doesn't say to Joseph,
you are to name him Jesus because God saves.
He doesn't say that.
Instead, he says you're to name him Jesus
because he will save his people from their...
anyone?
Sins.
It's between Dax and Lucy this afternoon.
They're both like, we got it.
Sorry if anyone else had their hand up.
I apologize.
Yes, because he will save his people from their sins.
And I know this word, you know, sins.
I don't know.
It's like, at least in the broader culture,
it's kind of a churchy, Christiany thing.
But, you know, no one really uses this term much.
And honestly, even in the church,
people kind of shy away from the sin language,
especially if you talk about a person.
It's just not as popular as it was 50 years ago
for someone to say, like, I'm a sinner, you know,
saved by grace.
That term even, sinner,
I'm not sure how it kind of hits your ears.
But I want to name that I think the power of it
or why I wouldn't want us to just leave it behind
or something is because...
Well, let me explain it like this.
I think it's very easy for us as human beings
to begin to sort of presume our own innocence.
You know, like, in other words,
we're kind of tough on others
and maybe a little bit easy on ourselves
in the sense, like, when others mess up,
we get real hacked off at them
and we're like, well, of course they did that
because they're wicked people.
You know, or you watch the news
and you get all pissed off, or sorry,
hacked off at whoever you're, you know,
just like, oh my gosh, well, that's, of course they did.
Like, that's just people.
You know, they need Jesus.
But me, I just make mistakes.
I don't mean to.
I'm not a sinner.
And so I think this term, it might be,
I'm not sure how it hits your ears,
you know, this idea of he will save his people
from their sins.
And of course, you know,
it kind of maybe hits us in a way
that we want to avoid it,
but the truth is it's talking about me,
not just them, those people.
It's talking about me,
that I am in need of saving.
I was thinking of how this plays out,
this kind of tendency to kind of push,
you know, sin onto others in a way for myself.
I was thinking of the way,
when we watch like movies,
we often identify with characters
who are like, you know, the hero,
or sometimes the victim.
Amen.
Merry Christmas.
Yes, we're doing church.
They're so happy for us, I guess.
So I was thinking about when we watch a film,
you know, we'll often identify,
like kind of resonate with,
like the hero, maybe the victim.
We kind of see ourselves, you know, in them.
But who do we almost never identify with?
You say it, the villain.
Yeah.
And I actually had a little experience of this.
I was watching with my kiddos,
and then my nephew and my nieces.
We were watching the movie Spies in Disguise.
Has anyone seen Spies in Disguise?
It was a good one.
It was really good.
I think it was maybe Disney+.
It was one of the one million streaming services that we use.
I can't remember which one.
One of those.
And we were watching this movie,
and so the basic plot is there's this awesome,
kind of James Bond-esque spy.
His name's Lance.
I think he's played by Will Smith.
It's an animated, you know, movie.
And Lance, he's just, I mean, he's amazing.
But the thing is, he has a little problem.
He gets turned into a pigeon, about a third in the movie.
And so basically the whole plot is he's trying to,
they're trying to stop the bad guy,
and Lance is trying to get turned back into a human.
Right?
So that's kind of the whole plot.
But in the process, as he's a pigeon,
some other pigeons kind of latch on to Lance,
and they start following him around.
You guys, if you've seen this movie,
you remember there's, I had to look up the names later,
because I don't know if they say the names,
but it's like, Lovey is one.
Fan, what is it?
Uh-huh, you're all masked.
Jeff?
Jeff is one?
Okay, Jeff, apparently.
So there's a few pigeons, okay?
That's the point.
And, but then there's one.
His name, I think it's, is this Jeff,
or is it Crazy Eyes?
It's the one, the crazy pigeon.
He just said, I love it,
he just said, I love it,
which comes up in my story, my friend.
So we're all watching, and suddenly,
I don't remember, one of the kids yells out,
which pigeon are you?
And everyone starts pointing at the television
and naming their pigeon.
And of course, who did they all start choosing?
They immediately start choosing the awesome pigeons,
like Lance, the hero, the cool guy,
and they start choosing their pigeons.
And then suddenly, Judah, my nephew, he's very brave,
he points at the crazy pigeon,
which you need to know,
this pigeon is a little bit mongerous,
because he eats anything and then vomits it up
throughout the movie, right?
It's really gross.
But Judah is like, I'm that crazy pigeon!
And then throughout the whole movie,
he keeps reminding us of this.
He's like, everyone, look!
Look what I'm doing!
Look at it!
Like, he just keeps identifying.
Now, here's what I love.
A, I love that Judah's so brave and confident in himself,
because while everyone else was choosing the hero pigeons,
he's like, I'm the unique one.
He does that.
But noticeably, who no one identified with
was, of course, the villain.
None of the kids said, oh yeah!
That terrible, evil, malevolent man!
I see myself in him!
Like, no one did that, right?
And just to be, I'm not picking on them,
because it's okay, this is what we do as humans.
Like, we watch a film, we look in the world,
we resonate with certain people,
and we kind of, well, we're just,
we're tempted to kind of presume our own innocence.
You might say, we're very tempted to kind of distance ourselves
from the evil and the malevolence and the,
oh, that's kind of bad, you know, in the world.
But this is simply not where the Christmas story begins.
Instead, Christmas begins with this very kind of humbling acknowledgement
that I am not as well put together,
and I don't have it all together as much as I like to imagine,
or at the very least as much as I project to the world,
but that in fact, I'm in need of saving.
That I am, to use the old language, a sinner.
And so this is where the Christmas story begins.
God saves.
But it doesn't end there, right?
And here we can really come to, I think,
one of the most beautiful parts of Christmas,
and really of the Christian faith as a whole,
which is the answer of how does God save?
And the way he saves is found in the second name,
Emmanuel, which means God with us.
And this is who Jesus is, right?
He's God with us in our midst.
In other words, God saves not by shaming us and blaming us.
God saves not by lecturing at us and shouting
and using fear or violence or coercion to make us.
Instead, what does God do?
God saves by drawing close to us.
God saves by drawing close.
God is with us.
He's with us in the midst of all of our struggles
and our pain and our craziness.
God is with us in the midst of job loss,
in the midst of sickness.
I'm just seeing faces and I know just so much
of what so many of you have been through this year.
And I just want you to know that the Christmas message
is that God is with you
and that he's going to lead you out of this.
And he's going to do it, not at a distance,
but he's going to do it by entering into your life.
He's doing it by coming into our world
and meeting you right where you are at.
In other words, there is nowhere you can go
that God's love will not find you.
That's God's message to you this Christmas.
There is nowhere you can go where God's love,
God's grace, God's mercy will not find you.
God saves by drawing close.
I'll close with this story.
It's from Matthew chapter 12.
Because I think one of the beautiful things about Jesus
is not simply that he took on this title, this name,
Emmanuel, and it was just a thing kind of put on him.
I think the beautiful part is that Jesus lived it.
He lived that name.
And this is a beautiful example.
It's Matthew chapter 12.
It's not a really well-known story,
but there was a man who was brought to Jesus
and he was, three things, he was possessed by a demon.
And however you kind of interpret that,
whether it's a severe mental illness
or I read it in a more kind of literal way
that I think there's actually evil
and that can be kind of in a spiritual sense.
So he's somehow consumed by evil.
That's one problem.
And then the text says that he's blind.
And then third, that he's mute.
He can't speak.
And I think what's so tragic about this picture
is how painful to be consumed by evil itself
and then you're unable to see beauty.
And this man was unable to sort of unburden himself
through his speech, to share what he's going through.
He's just sort of entombed in his suffering.
And so someone brings this man to Jesus.
And apparently this man was well-known
because a whole crowd kind of gathers to watch.
And we don't know the details of what exactly happens,
like how this happens.
But I imagine that because the man was blind
that Jesus probably placed his hands on him
and then he could hear, right?
The man could hear.
And that he just whispered some sort of prayer.
But what we know is suddenly the man,
for maybe the first time in years,
his mind is set free.
All of a sudden he can see.
And he can speak.
And I'm guessing he starts shouting like a hallelujah
and just freaking out.
Because what we know is the text says
that all of the people that were gathered
were completely amazed.
And I'm thinking, why were they amazed?
Well, they were amazed because they watched
as that man was saved.
But how?
And saved from what?
Saved from what?
I mean, the man was saved from his fear,
saved from his torment,
saved from his grief,
saved from this life that's just a shattered life.
It's like he's in a moment.
He's healed, restored.
But here's the beautiful thing.
How was he saved?
He was saved because Jesus lived the name.
He was saved because God came,
wrapped himself in flesh,
came among us,
and is with us.
And he stood right next to that man
and brought hope and life and healing to him.
See, this is what God does.
God saves by drawing close.
And I love this quote from Richard Rohr.
He says,
God loves things by becoming them.
And I think that's the message this Christmas.
That God loves things by becoming them.
God saves by drawing close to us.
And there's nowhere we can go
where God's love will not find us.
Amen?
Amen.
So we're going to go ahead and take communion.
So if you got a little packet,
you can go ahead and start just opening that up.
I'll lead you through taking the elements in just one moment.
But this practice of communion is,
it's basically a picture.
And it's a moment to remember
the truth that we were just talking about.
That God has come among us.
That in the life of this little baby,
God draws close.
In the cross, God draws close.
In resurrection, God draws close to us.
So that's kind of what's going on here.
And it's what we're remembering.
So this moment itself, though,
goes back to the night that Jesus was betrayed.
This was just before the cross.
That he had one final meal with his disciples.
And during that meal,
at one point, he stood up at the table
and he held up a loaf of bread.
And then he broke the bread.
And this was alluding to what was to come the next day,
which was his crucifixion.
And he broke the bread and he said,
this is my body,
broken for you.
If you'd like to go ahead, you can take your bread.
And then Jesus held up a cup of wine.
With his disciples.
And he said, and this,
this is my blood.
Whenever you eat this bread,
whenever you drink this cup,
remember me.
You can go ahead and take your wine.
And so for 2000 years,
Christians have participated in this,
we call it a sacrament.
It's this,
these very simple elements
that through God's presence
become a sign of God's closeness to us.
And so as you take them
and as you reflect on these elements,
I pray that you just remember
that it's God drawing close to you.
So I promised that
we would have someone read that scripture
or actually a few someones.
So we're going to start with one Dax Tilford.
He's going to come on up and read this passage.
This is how the birth of Jesus,
the Messiah came about.
His mother Mary was pledged to be Mary.
His mother Mary was pledged to be Mary to Joseph.
But before they came together,
she was found to be pregnant through the Holy Spirit
because Joseph, her husband,
was faithful to the law
and yet did not want to expose her to the public.
This race he had in mind to divorce her quietly.
But after he had considered this,
an angel of the Lord appeared to him in a dream
and said,
Joseph, son of David,
do not be afraid to take Mary home as your wife
because what is conceived in her
is from the Holy Spirit.
Matthew 1.18-20
Alright.
Next is Lucy Branson.
She will give birth to a son
in order to give him the name Jesus
because he will save people from their sins.
All this took place to fulfill
what the Lord had said through the prophet.
The virgin will conceive and give birth to a son.
They will call him Emmanuel.
When Joseph woke up,
he did what the angel of the Lord had commanded him
and took Mary home as his wife.
But he did not consummate their marriage
until she gave birth to a son
and he gave him the name Jesus.
Matthew 1.19-21
Weigh in a manger, no crib for a bed
And little Lord Jesus lay down his sweet head
The stars in the sky look down where he lay
The little Lord Jesus asleep on the hay
The cattle are lowing, the baby awakes
But little Lord Jesus, no crying he makes
I love thee, Lord Jesus, look down from the sky
And stay by my cradle till morning is nigh
Be near me, Lord Jesus, I ask thee to stay
Close by me forever and love me, I pray
Bless all the dear children in thy tender care
And bid us for heaven to live with thee there
Let us adore him, Christ the Lord
For you alone are worthy
We'll give you all the glory
Christ the Lord
Thank you guys so much for being here this afternoon
We also want to just do a quick reminder that next Sunday
We are taking this Sunday off
So we will see everyone back online
This next year, it's going to be January the 3rd
So we'll see you guys back at that time
I do want to do a quick Christmas blessing
I picked this one mainly because when I started thinking about Christmas in general
Christmas is a season of hope
We kind of walk with hope when we talk about Jesus
And we talk about the Lord Christ everywhere we go
And so this is something that came to my mind when just thinking about Christmas
So let's be people of hope
Let's live hope in our hearts as we share the hope of Jesus
With everyone that you meet
Share hope by noticing someone's humanity
Share hope by listening to someone's story
Share hope by praying for our world
And let this Christmas season let us see, feel, and share hope
So as you go out to the wonder of God's creation
Share hope with all that you meet
Merry Christmas
Thank you guys so much for being with us
Y'all are welcome to leave as soon as you're ready
As you go, we're going to just send you out with this happy blessing for the next year
Because I think we're all looking forward to a better 2021
But feel free to mingle or pack up, leave
You do not need to stay and freeze
Have yourself a merry little Christmas
Let your heart be light
Next year all our troubles will be out of sight
Have yourself a merry little Christmas
Make the yuletide gay
Next year all our troubles will be miles away
Once again as in olden days
Happy golden days of yore
Faithful for us who are dear to us
You'll be near to us once more
Someday soon we all will be together
If the fates allow
Until then we'll have to muddle through somehow
So have yourself a merry little Christmas
Have yourself a merry little Christmas
Have yourself a merry little Christmas now
My world's standing still
On this moonlit hill
Alone
The stars fill my eyes
Changing beautiful signs
My world's standing still
On this moonlit hill
Alone
The stars fill my eyes
Changing beautiful signs
Them voices singing in the sky
Calling through a silent night
Bring me to my knees
Holy host let glory glow
For the Lord is with us
Let all the earth shout
Worthy, worthy
Love has come to save us
Holy, holy, holy
How could this little child so humble me
Come out, come and save me
When in my heart and soul
The angels seem to know
Hear them singing on and on
Holy host cry glory, glory
For the Lord is with us
Let all the earth shout
Worthy, worthy
Love has come to save us
Holy, holy, holy
Allelu, alleluia
Holy host cry glory, glory
For the Lord is with us
Let all the earth shout
Worthy, worthy
Love has come to save us
Holy, holy, holy
Love has come to save me
Allelu, alleluia
O come, O come, Emmanuel
And ransom captive Israel
That mourns in lonely exile here
Until the Son of God appear
Rejoice, rejoice, Emmanuel
Shall come to thee, O Israel
O come, O come, Emmanuel
O come, Thou Dayspring, come and cheer
Our spirits by Thine advent here
Disperse the gloomy clouds of night
And its dark shadows put to flight
Rejoice, rejoice, Emmanuel
Shall come to thee, O Israel
O Israel
O come, Thou King of David, come
And open wide our heavenly home
Make safe the way that leads on high
And close the path to misery
Rejoice, rejoice, Emmanuel
Shall come to thee, O Israel
SILENT NIGHT
Silent night, holy night
All is calm, all is bright
Round yon virgin, mother and child
Holy infant so tender and mild
Sleep in heavenly peace
SILENT NIGHT
Silent night, holy night
Shepherds quake at the sight
Glories stream from heaven afar
Heavenly hosts sing Alleluia
Christ the Savior is born
SILENT NIGHT
With the angels let us sing
Alleluia to the King
Christ the Savior is born
SILENT NIGHT
AWAY IN A MANGER
Away in a manger, no crib for a bed
The little Lord Jesus lay down His sweet head
The stars in the sky look down where He lay
The little Lord Jesus asleep on the hay
AWAY IN A MANGER
The cattle are lowing, the baby awakes
The little Lord Jesus, no crying He makes
I love you Lord Jesus, look down from the sky
And stay by my cradle till morning is nigh
AWAY IN A MANGER
Be near me Lord Jesus, I ask Thee to stay
Close by me forever and ever I pray
Bless all the dear children in Thy tender care
And fit us for heaven to live with Thee there
AWAY IN A MANGER
Away in a manger, no crib for a bed
The little Lord Jesus lay down His sweet head
The Lord of all creation lay down His sweet head
The Saviour of the nation lay down His sweet head
AWAY IN A MANGER
I have travelled many moonless nights
Cold and weary